america relaying from a surge in
violence across the country the
president in buffalo new york today
after the tragic mass shooting there
that claimed the lives of 10 people
biden honoring the victims while
condemning the hateful attack and
calling for more gun control
what happened here is simple and
straightforward terrorism
terrorism
domestic terrorism white supremacy is a
poison and it's been allowed to fester
and grow right in front of our eyes we
need to say as clearly and forced as we
can
that the ideology of white supremacy has
no place in america there are certain
things we can do
we can keep assault weapons off our
streets
we've done it before
i did it when he passed the crime bill
last time and violence went down
shootings went down
comes amid an enormous surge in violence
over the weekend 17 people were shot in
a single incident in downtown milwaukee
in chicago at least 33 people were shot
and five fatally so chicago mayor lori
lightfoot banning unaccompanied minors
from millennium park after 6 pm in the
wake of a 16 year old's fatal shooting
there and gun homicides reaching their
highest level in 25 years during the
covid pandemic so a lot to get to on
this particular topic and the rest of
the show jesse where do you land on the
there's the crime that happened in
massacre in buffalo and then there's
this additional crime that we see all
across the country i'm not saying that
they're the same but you have this story
that is so tragic up there and the
president goes to visit and then you
have these other stories where you don't
get a visit well he plays peek-a-boo
with hate crime right so if it's a black
supremacist closes his eyes white
supremacist he goes beast mode and
campaigns on it same thing with street
crime if it's black owned back crime he
ignores it if there's a white police
officer involved he's getting the bull
horn out and he's in campaign mode i was
walking to work today beautiful day here
in new york and i saw these junior high
school kids it's a black kid white kid
spanish kid and they're all just holding
each other's shoulders walking down
fifth avenue across from the park that's
nice and it's just a nice thing to see
and then you know they graduate and they
go to college and they get in the
workforce and their minds just get
poisoned by these politicians and
pundits because that's what's happening
joe biden tries to make black people
scared and white people feel guilty it's
this emotional grip that he tries to put
on the country because it's good for
democrat party politics and the american
people are waking up to this i think we
see the more we study
these crimes and how they're covered and
how they're exploited by politicians
that these politicians are just trying
to chop us up into different groups pit
it's against each other and just get
away with everything they can for
political power we're done with it and i
don't like to be lectured by a guy like
joe biden this corrupt old-timer whose
son uses the n-word who pals around with
segregationists and klansmen and who's
had every single position on crime you
could possibly imagine he swoops in he's
now the soul of the nation give me a
break
on this whole thing about how this could
have been stopped
new york has this red flag law so this
guy says he's going to shoot up a school
and he's suicidal and they interview him
at the school and then they send him to
a psych ward and the police interview
him
i don't know and they release him and he
gets and shoots up this whole
shopping center they didn't take away
his gun they didn't look what he was
looking on at the internet i mean bang
up job their red flag laws aren't even
effective their gun laws aren't even
effective so you got to really just take
a broader look at this thing this guy
was radicalized on the internet during
the coveted lockdowns during these
stupid fouchy lockdowns that did nothing
and his family missed it the school
missed it the police missed it we all
missed it and he's an ugly killer and i
hope he gets fried geraldo they don't
fry him in new york well they should
uh
can i tell you about a dinner i had with
president from february 2018 the day
after the parkland school massacre he
and the first lady had just visited the
victims in the hospital and he came to
the dinner he was rattled i was at
mar-a-lago it was a private dinner uh
eric and uh and don junior were there
and laura
but it was just us and we were really
head-to-head and the president asked
what can i do i mean those wounds were
horrible the rifle that uh crews had
used to kill these 17 kids was was these
wounds they were torn looked like war
victims
and i said uh you know the kids uh you
know underage why don't you why don't
you pass a juvenile assault weapons ban
a juvenile assault weapons ban if you
can't buy a beer you can't buy buy an ar
why if you can't drive a semi you can't
have a assault weapon what's wrong with
that the president liked the idea he
said i'm not afraid of the nra a couple
of days passed and it turns out he was
afraid of the nra
i think that it is impossible now to get
any kind of meaningful
gun control legislation passed i think
the country has gone crazy drunk uh
we're hooked on on weapons and more
weapons now than there are americans out
there i what surprises me isn't how
frequent these incidents of mass
killings are it is how infrequent they
are given the fact that there are so
many weapons out there and the
opportunity to put extended magazines
and wear body armor and have a helmet uh
you know ballistic head to toe i think
that though that emily gets to the point
though that if
we have these processes and either the
family or the school alerts the
authorities he goes to the hospital for
a mental health evaluation nothing is
put in his file
we know that from that during the
coveted lockdown he was
increasingly isolated he didn't want to
even go to school when it opened he
decided to stay home and then he goes
and he buys a gun when that when the
owner of the gun shop does the
background check nothing comes up right
i think what actually was the damning
area in this particular situation was
the opacity of those hospital records
that to this day they still refuse to
confirm or give any transparency into so
if anything i think given the high
stakes consequences the possibility of
such then it doesn't matter if he's a
juvenile those records should be
absolutely available to law enforcement
or those running a background checks
gerald are you saying there's more
weapons in this country than americans
to me
is exactly why we need to support those
who are lawfully owning them and support
those who are putting their lives on the
line every day to try to control crime
rather than simply regulate it and take
it away from those law-abiding citizens
and i agree with you jesse that this
president has been all over the place
and even right now when he's talking
about issuing an executive order for
police reform or for criminal justice
he's absolutely in all the wrong arenas
when seven to eight out of every 10
gunshot victims homicide victims are
young african-american men why then is
he focusing only on the gun regulator
being for for racist bias hate crimes
that's the tiniest portion and if you
really care about minorities in this
country then you would care about the
black on black crime that is plaguing
our inner cities that the da's who are
feckless and incompetent are doing
nothing to try to prevent because
they're all just paying lip service to
this progressive woke left that don't
know what they're talking about greg do
you want to zoom out about the way the
crime is approached the way people look
at it zoom out i shall zoom out no it's
well you know
there are 330 340 million people in
america but there's only one president
and uh this president says that american
democracy is his greatest danger in 80
years
who's president
he is
you know
he has the white house he has the house
he has the senate and we have the
greatest threat to american democracy
while he's president when he was
claiming to unify us and to create a
sense of normalcy so what is going on
and why is there a statistic of 78 of
america thinking we're going in the
wrong direction it's him
he's created he has replaced patriotism
with identity politics we're not having
it anymore this has nothing to do with
the crime in buffalo this has to do how
people are so frustrated so what do you
see after buffalo or any of these major
mass murders you don't see the failed
policies that led to the crime right the
buffalo shooter was pre-detected and
imprisoned and let go so why is that in
common with all the other crimes that we
mentioned
we put a lot of these people behind bars
and they're out
he's just like all the other criminals
all of the other benefactors of the no
cash bail and the media and the
democrats lack the ability to handle
multiple variables from because they
lack a mental dashboard they're like a
pilot that doesn't fly by the controls
so whenever there's a problem they only
see what's around them right they only
see their peers in the newsroom those
are the people that they listen to the
reason why the five has been
consistently successful in predicting
almost every major issue is because we
possess a mental dashboard
we have we are able to understand
statistics probability law enforcement
experience so when we saw no cash bail
come out whether it was four or five
years ago we said this thing's gonna
suck and you know why because of
recidivism because the probability of
somebody recommitting crimes the
statistics show this right law
enforcement experience tells you this
but none of the progressives and none of
the media actually looked at these
statistics because they don't have a
mental dashboard right they're a plane
flying blind with one variable and that
variable is only
what can be construed as racism so what
they do is they let criminals out
because keeping them in is is is racist
they justify riots as a form of protest
because if you don't say that that's
that's racist and then what you have is
a ferguson effect which causes causes of
decline in arrest an increase in smash
and grab crimes murder gang crime all
these things result from an inability to
see the root causes these variables we
have we have been talking about this for
so long we understand this the problem
is when you operate by one statistic and
once or one belief and one belief only
in one filter you are going to be wrong
the people should be behind bars aren't
or institutionalized they aren't they
justify riots as retribution that
ultimately leads to so much more crime
but the worst thing about it is biden is
incapable and incoherent to understand
this he doesn't even have a single
variable the only variable he operates
now is on the identity pollock that race
and that's all he can say and that's why
when people listen to him they don't
listen they don't listen 80 percent of
the country says dude he's taken us to a
cliff and i think i think tucker was
pretty damn good last night when he
talked about rwanda that what where can
identity politics take you it doesn't
take you any place good
so that's mike can i just add one little
thing
here we go
i think what about what about ism
uh it leads us nowhere what about
chicago 33 shot and uh over the weekend
five kill what about philly the two
pregnant women what about the bronx the
11 year old what about what about what
about
that does not alter the fact that what
happened in buffalo was a white racist
mass murder of mostly black people and
uh if everything else is true that you
said greg but i didn't even say that
there was no way what about isn't in
there what you're doing is you're
redefining what i said geraldo please
don't do that please don't do that what
i'm talking about is context if you
don't like context that's your issue
well if you don't like to talk about
white racism then the rest of it is what
did i say no no no no no no i'm talking
about how a crime could have been
prevented and how all of these could
have prevented that's the that's the
string and all these i never disowned
the fact that the guy is racist right
and i think that the fact that all these
things could have been prevented is what
is frustrating and why you have 75 or
more people in america saying that the
country's going in the wrong direction i
went on brian kilmeade i want you to do
me a favor i want you to click to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
fox you can get it all here on youtube
so subscribe right now